new food can only be taken when the old
one is out of the stomach
everything is good in moderation
let food be the medicine and Medicine be
the food
very often the best medicine is to go
without it
if you are in a bad mood go for a walk
if you are still in a bad mood
go for another walk
excessive food causes disease
all disease begins in the gut
any excitement in strong manifestation
of feelings is dangerous
in everything
a slow transition from one to another is
important
when in a state of hunger
one ought not to undertake labor
never put off treatment
until later
both sleep and insomnolence
when immoderate or bad
tell me what you eat
and I'll tell you what illness do you
have
disease that come from overwork are
cured by rest
and those that come from idleness are
cured by work
the human soul develops until death
time always contains an opportunity
the natural healing Force within each of
us is the greatest force in getting well
it is necessary to treat not only the
disease
but also to counteract the causes that
cause it
disease always comes either from an
excess or from a deficiency
that is
from an imbalance
any excess is contrary to Nature
doctors first commandment
Do no harm
when the brain is healthy and in a calm
state
a person thinks sensibly
the drunkenness of fathers and mothers
is the cause of the weakness and
sickness of children
the doctor heals the disease
but nature heals
some believe that we feel with the heart
because it shrinks and freezes with
sadness and worries
however
the heart is not capable of
understanding and thinking
only the brain can do this
and it is he who gives rise to our
feelings
hunger weakens
weakens and kills a person
heavy food destroys the human body
therefore you need to look for the
middle
in despair the sick person brings
himself closer to death
just as Clothiers clean cloth
knocking it out of dust
so gymnastics cleanses the body
that which cannot be cured with medicine
is cured with a knife
that which is not cured by the knife
is cured by Red Hot Iron
that which cannot be cured by Red Hot
Iron
should be considered incurable
work
good spirits and the striving of the
mind for perfection
for knowledge lead to results that Adorn
life
neither say shitty or hunger
and nothing else is good if one
transgresses the measure of nature
declare the past diagnose the present
foretell the future
idleness is the source of all vices
where there is no idleness
there is no evil
[Music]
frequent and causeless fatigue pretends
an impending illness
the doctor is a philosopher
for there is no great difference between
wisdom and Medicine
marriage is a fever inside out
starts hot and ends cold
the brain contains our mind
and Madness and insanity
and all our fears and Horrors
including dreams
as well as all our abilities and
negligence
burning yourself will always make you
shine for others
there are in fact two things
to know and to believe one knows
to know is science
to believe one knows is ignorance
avoid sex in old age because at this age
it is safer to use other sources of
pleasure
do not tell your illness to anyone
otherwise you risk getting advice that
can harm you
foreign